des chiffres que nous enregistrons
depuis quelques jours dans notre pays
j'aurais tendance à parler de
raz-de-marée s'agissant du variant
omicron les chiffres qui seront publiés
ce soir par santé publique france montre
l'augmentation continuelle du nombre de
contaminations dans notre pays ce sont
des chiffres qui donnent le vertige il y
à 208 milles français qui ont été
diagnostiqués positifs au co vide au
cours des 24 dernières heures j'ai fait
un rapide calcul avant de vous rejoindre
ça veut dire que vingt-quatre heures sur
vingt-quatre jour et nuit toutes les
deux secondes toutes les secondes par
dont toutes les secondes dans le pays de
français plus de deux français sont
diagnostiqués positifs au coronavirus
plus de 2 français chaque seconde nous
n'avons jamais connu une telle situation
il y en a partout dans tous les
territoires partout dans tous les
milieux et le virus circule très vite si
j'extrapole un peu on est probablement à
ce soir en comptant les cas
d'aujourd'hui à un million de français
qui doivent être positif au corona virus
à l'heure à laquelle je vous parle et
qui sont diagnostiqués comme tels
auxquels il faut ajouter un certain
nombre de personnes asymptomatiques qui
ne sont pas testés donc probablement
plus d'un million de français sont
positifs actuellement au corona ville je
dis pas positif il ya une semaine j'ai
dit aujourd'hui un jour donné
si on considère qu'on est entre 3 et 5
eca contact par français on peut
considérer qu'il ya 10% de la population
française qui à l'heure à laquelle je
vous parle qu'à contacter donc autour de
vous sur dix personnes y en a une qui
doit être considéré comme cas contactez
pas forcément positive bien sûr